Freyja allen's role as princess Siri on
Netflix's original series that Witcher
is undoubtedly the breakout moment of
her career and only 18 years old
allons only just getting started but
she's already had some extraordinarily
good luck even before landing this major
gig born in Oxfordshire England in 2001
Alan told Digital Spy that she underwent
a confusing audition process for The
Witcher as she didn't really know she
was auditioning to play ciri and
initially thought she landed a smaller
part now that she's settled into the
starring role she's apparently beloved
by the production team director mark
jobs took a moment to lavish her with
praise and a quick question and answer
session on Twitter describing her
portrayal is ciri as quote luminous
fierce charismatic with the presence and
strength of an old soul nothing to you
to be concerned about a dismissive tone
said it is
alan screen presence is indeed powerful
and many of you witcher watchers at home
have probably scratched your head and
wondered where you've seen the actress
before while their career has only just
taken off in the past year Alan may look
familiar to many after attending the
same prestigious Academy as Harry Potter
franchise icon Emma Watson the
headington school in Oxford Allen began
her artistic secondary education at the
prestigious National Film and Television
School and Buckinghamshire from there
Allen went on to study at the Art
University Bournemouth and starred in a
short film called captain fierce in the
short Allen plays Linda a girl who can
only meet up with her friend Danny once
a year because her family is part of a
traveling carnival they find an
abandoned damaged boat and decide to fix
it so they can run off together the
short appears to have been uploaded to
YouTube as part of the hype building up
around the witcher's casting
announcements as many comments on the
video speak positively about Allen's
pending role as series before being
taken under the wing of Henry cavils
Geralt of Rivia on the witcher allen's
first big role was as a younger version
of martial arts expert minerva a major
character on AMC's action series into
the badlands the single episode in which
Allen appeared includes a flashback to
when a teenage Minerva was enslaved by
one of the show's post-apocalyptic
barons
following a short stint on into the
badlands she landed a small role on an
installment of the BBC's 2019 miniseries
adaptation of the beloved sci-fi novel
War of the Worlds going from those roles
to standing front and center as part of
the witcher's major character triad is
one heck of a quantum leap but that
momentum is here to stay for at least
the next couple of years The Witcher was
greenlit for a second season even before
all eight episodes went live on Netflix
so that's a great sure thing for allen's
future however allen's early career
renaissance doesn't stop there
in 2020 Freya Allen will make her
feature film debut in the action
thriller gunpowder milkshake details on
the plot of gunpowder milkshake are
still slim and there's no trailer just
yet but Allen will once again play a
younger counterpart of the protagonist
in this case Karen Gillan's lead
character Eva Gillan will co-star
alongside Game of Thrones alum Lena
Headey as a mother-daughter assassin duo
out to end the head of a gang for whom
they used to kill another woman in
training for the warrior class should
feel nice and familiar for Allen now
right here's hoping Allen will be a
fresh new leader on the upward swing of
this trend of female led original action
films Allen's other project which is
still in pre-production is a British
program for Sky media's new foray into
original programming sixth episode
miniseries entitled the third day which
is about the residents of a mysterious
island who are set on preserving their
traditions at any cost
of all the actresses forthcoming
offerings The Witcher Season 2 is the
farthest out and we're sure she'll land
a few more high-profile gigs in the
meantime following her star-making turn
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
The Witcher are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]